so donald trump recently changed his
rhetoric on coronavirus and reportedly
it is uh not because he realized this is
a serious problem
it's because aids explained to him that
his
own supporters are getting sick and
dying
last week we sort of noticed the change
in donald trump's tone on coronavirus
like as an example
he restarted these coronavirus press
briefings and at the first one he
regularly uh pulled out his mask he has
the mask with him sort of as a prop now
talked about the importance of wearing
masks that it may get worse before it
gets better which
you know any admission that anything
that everything is not perfect is kind
of a big step with donald trump who has
suggested everything's fine since the
start of this pandemic
however it seems as though the reasons
are different than the ones maybe we
imagined our initial analysis was just a
simple
trump's desperate he understands he's
losing in the polls
despite publicly insisting that he's not
losing in the polls and the polls are
fake
we actually know that internally trump
has been furious about polling in which
he's losing to joe biden
but now according to a new poor uh
report from the washington post
people close to trump claim
that the reason trump's tone has changed
on coronavirus is because advisors have
brought him maps
and they've explained that our people
as they call them trump voters are
disproportionately getting sick
and dying and they actually showed trump
some projections that if
we continue to see these spikes in
battleground states minnesota
um not so much a battleground state
anymore
wisconsin michigan et cetera that it
could disproportionately
hurt trump because it would be more of
his supporters that might end up getting
sick and dying now there are a few
things here that are completely
outrageous
the first is again the total lack of
empathy
we know donald trump seems almost
constitutionally unable to experience
empathy
and indeed if one thing gets him to
change his tune on coronavirus it's
getting told
that his own voters may be the one that
died from the virus
it's another indictment of donald
trump's personality and morality and
total lack of empathy but
the really wacky thing here is i've been
asked essentially this question for
months on friday
questions on live calls via email
voicemails people say you know david the
leftists
are more likely than the right wingers
to wear a mask
to observe social distancing to take the
virus
more seriously is it possible
that this will lead to more trumpists
dying from the virus
and maybe affect the election in
november now
it's of course theoretically possible
and even plausible
but the numbers to flip a state would
have to be really bad to the point where
you have such a degree of death and so
much
more among would-be trump voters than
would-be biden voters that it could
really
impact the election results but it seems
that this is actually becoming a
consideration within the trump campaign
republicans
ignoring guidelines that are being
followed
by democrats could kill
just enough additional republicans that
it hands donald trump a loss
in some state in november and what's
notable there
is the partisan difference in the care
that different people are taking
and the seriousness with which our side
is taking the virus and it's becoming
politically relevant
this is really no different than when
you know an anti-gay republican
changes their view because they have a
kid who's gay
or a nephew or a niece or something like
that
it's just on a grand scale trump is
changing
course when it finally impacts him
directly out of personally selfish
reasons
and november could be an absolute
rebuke of this absolute lunatic
and we've got to take the republicans in
the senate down
with us because this is nothing short of
a death death cult
at this point and they have to be voted
out on november third there's really no
other alternative
and what has finally gotten trump to pay
attention to coronavirus
is that his supporters may be dying
at greater rates than democrats are
dying and you know a few people emailed
me
they said if trump loses in november
he will always have coronavirus as the
excuse trump will say
i handled coronavirus beautifully i was
the victim of circumstance and the
reality is that
it is true in a literal sense
uh and trump will never realize and
certainly never admit that he was simply
a disastrous president his delusions of
grandeur
his narcissism would not allow anything
else he'll say he lost because the virus
happened during his presidency
the truth is actually quite the opposite
national emergencies
often strengthen the incumbent and
there are many world leaders right now
who are more popular than ever
because they took this seriously and
they handled it well it
new zealand comes to mind uh finland
ireland there's a whole list of places
trump's approval rating actually
went up early in the pandemic because of
that rally around the flag effect george
w bush benefited from it in 2001
after the 9 11 attacks bush squandered
it
by going into iraq after a group of
saudi arabians
attacked us trump again had the
opportunity
squandered it didn't take the virus
seriously until like 10 days ago
said 15 cases will soon be zero
everything's fine we have the most in
best testing economies coming back etc
etc
this is a president who turned a health
crisis into an even bigger national
catastrophe
and the reality is had he handled it
well
he would be sailing to reelection today
we have to make sure
he doesn't and after all this if he were
to get re-elected
we've just wasted a really an
unconscionable amount of time let's not
allow that to happen